the UN Human Rights Council held an
urgent debate on Wednesday over the
issue of alleged systemic racism on
police brutality in the u.s. the meeting
was called by the West African nation of
Burkina Faso and some multinational
concerns being raised one notable
absentee though the United States
reporting next kill'em open racial
unrest in the United States has prompted
54 African countries to call on the UN
Human Rights Council they want the
international body to look in to racism
and police brutality in the United
States and beyond the tragic events of
May 25th in Minneapolis in the US which
led to the death of George Floyd led to
protests throughout the world against
injustice and police brutality the
persons of African descent face on a
daily basis in many regions of the world
the death of George Floyd is
unfortunately not an isolated incident
we believe the situation in the United
States warrants urgent country specific
intervention and that a theme acts at
global investigation is also an order
the family of George Floyd has also
called on the UN to get involved
George Floyd's brother made an urgent
appeal at a landmark UN debate my
brother John Floyd is one of the many
black men and women that have been
murdered by police everything is I'm
asking you to help him I'm asking you to
help me I'm asking you to help us black
people in America the data has already
been collected black people in the
United States are two-and-a-half times
more likely to be killed by police than
whites and they are far more likely to
be killed by police Tasers an outrage
over these deaths has been dragging on
and building up for decades
the response from US officials was to
hail their own country's supposed
transparency and then to make a veiled
dig at those who criticize them we call
upon all governments to demonstrate the
same level of transparency and
accountability that the United States
and our Democratic partners practice but
the USA did not participate in the
debate on racism US representatives
weren't there why the United States has
withdrawn from the UN Human Rights
Council in response to criticism of
Israel we take this step because our
commitment does not allow us to remain a
part of a hypocritical and self-serving
organization that makes a mockery of
human rights and that trend of putting
pressure on international bodies
continues the United States is now
threatening sanctions against the
International Criminal Court because it
dared investigate the actions of US
troops in Afghanistan we will not stand
by as our people are threatened by a
kangaroo court and indeed I have a
message to many close allies around the
world your people could be next the
United States likes to think of itself
as the policemen of the world and just
like the police at home the United
States isn't too excited about being
expected to follow the same rules that
it claims to go around the world
enforcing Kaleb Maupin RT New York
you